qué balance se puede hacer de la región
en materia de Derechos Humanos podemos
hablar de avances o retrocesos
Pues mira estamos en una situación muy
difícil en América Latina con
descendiendo libertades y y derechos que
creíamos ya conquistados o sea estamos
defendiendo el derecho a votar por
nuestro representantes por los líderes y
a tener una democracia lo que hemos
visto es que las democracias en la
región han fallado en responder a
necesidades como
o problemas como la corrupción como la
pobreza como la inseguridad y han
emergido líderes movimientos
autoritarios que están ofreciendo
soluciones simplistas muchas veces
abusivas en términos de Derechos Humanos
a esos problemas tan complejos y una vez
que están en el poder estos líderes se
dedican a desmantelar las instituciones
democráticas y lo vemos por ejemplo en
El Salvador con el presidente bukele o
en Guatemala por ejemplo donde el
gobierno las autoridades
en lugar de perseguir a los corruptos
están persiguiendo a quien Investiga los
corruptos vimos el intento de golpe de
estado por el entonces presidente Pedro
Castillo en Perú en diciembre y el
domingo pasado aquí en Brasil donde yo
me encuentro una turba atacó las
instituciones democráticas de Brasil es
una situación muy preocupante la buena
noticia es que hay nuevos gobiernos en
la región que fueron elegidos el año
pasado
que tienen ese desafío demostrar que la
democracia funciona para la gente son
gobiernos en Brasil en Chile en Honduras
en Colombia que tienen ese desafío el
informe resalta un concepto particular y
es el desplazamiento fundamental del
poder en el mundo dice que todos los
gobiernos preocupados pueden actuar
contra los abusos cuando las medidas que
toman las principales potencias son
escasas o problemáticas a que hace
referencia esta formulación
miren nosotros creemos que la defensa de
los Derechos Humanos es una defensa de
todos los países del mundo es tiene que
ser un empeño colectivo y no es una
función en el pasado se confiaba en en
gobiernos en especialmente Estados
Unidos Europa etcétera los gobiernos con
más poder económico influencia Pero
ellos también siguen sus propios
intereses y han sido habido decisiones
que nos han defraudado por ejemplo de
Estados Unidos con acercamientos Arabia
Saudita o en Francia acercamientos con
el gobierno autoritario de Egipto
entonces hay un espacio para gobiernos
en todo el mundo para promover los
derechos humanos y es lo que es
fundamental es que esa promoción de los
Derechos sea coherente y consistente no
queremos que un gobierno de derecha
critique solo a gobiernos de izquierda y
se calle cuando hay en países gobernados
por líderes de derecha la defensa de
Derechos Humanos no tiene ideología
política y tiene que aplicarse en todos
los países por